[Music]
our team is the elite of the elite
the heart and soul of this very being
shoe
we protect when no one wants to protect
and we go above and beyond is nothing
you would say me people either a
refrigerator oh that's a very wash [ __ ]
[Music]
there's more to this job than just
swimming
Victoria leads the new owner the happy
Club trucks
murder all this started once Leeds took
over I thought we were lifeguards
everything that you guys are talking
about sounds like a really entertaining
but far-fetched TV show I just realize
she's running in solo
you see it too
how'd you find me here some Baywatch
[ __ ]
you go on tight night vision
my hand
you turned the canals into the goddamn X
Games
yeah that's cuz we were in lifeguard
pursuit there's no [ __ ] such thing as
lifeguard pursuit even if you were
police what you did would still be
totally illegal okay well I mean it's
good thing we're not police that
council's already cut our funding it's
up to us to restore the Baywatch brand
i'm matt brody ready for duty you just
flick my boobs
aye you should